[pensive music]
What if I fail?
Our lineage has a stand in between
the world of man and the supernatural.
But only when we have proven
ourselves worthy
by facing the trials
at the Great Balete Tree.
-[closet door opens, closes]
-[dagger swishes]
I don't feel ready.
You are the sixth child
of the sixth child,
the babaylan-mandirigma.
Healer and warrior.
You were born ready.
I wish I could go in with you.
She will have to do.
-[dagger shimmering]
-"She"?
[Anton] Sinag.
She's your twin, Alexandra.
I don't understand.
You told me my twin died at childbirth.
In a way.
I did everything we could
to save your sister.
[soft ringing]
[Anton] Forging that blade meant
that a part of her would always stay
and watch over our family.
Why are you telling me this now
when the trials are hours away?
This is when you need
your family the most.
The trials may seem daunting.
[Anton] But with Sinag,
you won't be facing them alone.
She will always be there beside you.
Your family will always
be there beside you.
[dramatic music]
[drumbeats]
[haunting music]
[haunting music continues]
[tense music]
[haunting music]
[music intensifies]
[vines rustle]